Elijah Cummings was the son of
sharecroppers who moved to Baltimore
Maryland for a better life raised to do
the right thing
Cummings took that belief first to law
school and then to Congress in 1996 most
recently Cummings ran investigations
into the trumpet ministrations alleged
corruption over the last two years
President Trump
set the tone from the top in his
administration that behaving ethically
and complying with the law is optional
ladies and gentlemen I've stopped by
here to simply say we're better than
that Cummings was chair of the House
Oversight Committee which launched
investigations into President Donald
Trump's handling of security clearances
and campaign finance law violations the
lifelong Democrat quickly earned Trump's
wrath for condemning his policy to
separate migrant children from their
parents at the u.s. southern border
Cummings district is a disgusting rat
and rodent infested mess but as word of
Cummings death spread on Thursday this
sympathy message from Trump on Twitter
my warmest condolences to the family and
many friends of congressman Elijah
Cummings Cummings had acquired
considerable political power on Capitol
Hill but he never forgot his
constituents in Baltimore he helped calm
tensions in the wake of the 2015 killing
of Freddie gray while he was in police
custody and he defended his city from
Trump's attacks on its character on
Capitol Hill tributes from Republicans
and Democrats alike he was in the
Congress Elisha was considered a North
Star he was a leader of towering
character and integrity he lived the
American dream by all accounts he was a
powerful and passionate voice on the
national stage and a strong advocate for
his neighbors his district and his
values when Trump's former lawyer
Michael Cohen testified about the secret
payouts Trump made to a former mistress
Cummings told him he had done the right
thing not just for himself but for the
country
well we're dancing with the Angels
the question will be asked in 2019 what
do we do to make sure we kept our
democracy intact did we stand on the
sidelines and say nothing it's a parent
doing nothing was never an option for
Elijah Cummings he was 68